[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre 78 nous sommes le
jeudi 11 janvier voici le programme de
ce soir un nouveau lieu de vie au cœur
de Versailles vient d'ouvrir pour les
jeunes de 16 à 25 ans baptiser
villeavenir c'est un projet dit en
France cette maison permettra aux
adolescents protégés par l'aide sociale
à l'enfance d'être accompagné dans leurs
rêves et leur ambition ce soir zoom
également sur cette entreprise basée à
traap qui propose des solutions
concrètes pour aller vers une société
plus inclusive rampe d'accès coussin
releveur ils sont indispensables pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
pourtant ces appareils manquent
cruellement en France seulement la
moitié des établissements en sont
équipés et le jeudi comme d'habitude
nous vous donnerons on nos idées de
sortie pour le weekend au programme de
ce soir concert comédie musicale soirée
techno ou encore cirque le weekend sera
festif dans les Evelin et puis comme
d'habitude l'invité du 78 en 2uxè partie
d'émission ce soir Didier Fischer le
maire de coignère sera avec nous pour
nous présenter les grands projets de
l'année 2024 dans sa commune voilà vous
connaissez le programme de ce soir avec
moi en plateau Gabriel Gontier bonsoir
bonsoir mathil journaliste de la
rédaction de tv70 comme d'habitude le
jeudi vous venez nous présenter vos
idées de sortie pour le weekend vous
allez également nous présenter les
informations du jour à retenir dans
quelques instants mais tout de suite
direction Versailles depuis septembre
2023 la Villa champlagarde accueille en
internat six jeunes suivis par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance l'objectif donner à
chacun les clés de la réussite un projet
inédit en France qui est soutenu par le
Département des yelines Clara de Frutos
et Julien Leroi se sont rendus sur place
ah
ou l'égalité des chances pour tous le
projet villeavenir était inauguré ce
jeudi 11 janvier à Versailles un lieu de
vie pensé comme un espace pour la
réussite de jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
accompagné par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des parcours de vie souvent
difficiles que la structure accompagne
grâce à des solutions éducatives
innovantes nous avons une jeune fille
qui est actuellement en train de
préparer sciencep et qui bénéficiera
d'un mentorat de quelqu'un qui a le même
parcours qu'elle mais pas que ça en
fonction des compétences qu'elle a à
développer on lui proposera tout un un
certain nombre d'ateliers d'activités de
rencontres inspirantes bien sûr il faut
que ce soit des des jeunes qui a un
talent mais surtout qui fassent la
démonstration de leur capacité à
s'engager véritablement de manière
authentique et dans leur travail pour
que le leur projet soi rendu possible
dans cette villeage chant la garde
accollé au domaine de Madame ellizabeth
six jeunes sont accompagnés en internat
depuis septembre 2023 un lieu permettant
l'accès à des études mais aussi le
développement de nouvelles compétences
gestion des émotions communication ou
méthodologie d'apprentissage des projets
individualisé et surmesure pour regagner
en confiance c'est vrai que c'est un
privilège parce que je suis une moi-même
une enfant de laad enfin j'étais une
enfant de laad la DAS c'est l'ancêtre de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance donc je me
reconnais dans ces parcours de vie de
ces jeunes dans tout ce qui a pu les
malmener finalement depuis leur plus
tendre enfance à un moment où ils
auraient dû être tout simplement
insouciant voilà re simplement des
enfants on est vraiment convaincu que la
qualité du cadre la qualité de
l'emplacement vont les aider à réussir
une vie quiil faut bien le dire était
pas forcément bien parti pour eux 1
million d'euros ont été investi par le
département pour réhabiliter cette
maison à la rentrée 2025 le site devrait
s'agrandir pour accueillir en interne
une douzaine de jeunes dans les ivines
près de 7000 enfants sont accompagnés
chaque année par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance allez c'est l'heure à présent
de faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel
Gontier on commence avec des problèmes
de transport dans le sud des ivelines
oui Mathilde et la colère gronde du côté
des usagers des transport en commun dans
le sud du département la raison Mathilde
depuis le 1er janvier la gestion du
trafic des Transports a changé demain
c'est maintenant l'entreprise Transdev
sudivline qui gère le secteur problème
cette dernière fait face à une pénurie
de conducteurs pour assurer le service
et notamment dans le secteur de la
Vallée de Chevreuse conséquence certains
élèves n'ont pas de bus pour aller à
l'école une situation jugée
incompréhensible par les maires de la
Vallée de Chevreuse ils ont saisi
île-de-fance mobinité et sa présidente
Valérie PCR selon les élus la situation
n'évoluera pas à court terme un mot de
football à présent Gabriel le
parisain-germain pourrait construire un
stade dans les Yvelines oui tout à fait
si le club de la capitale ne parvient
pas à racheter le Parc des Princes il
pourrait décider de construire un
nouveau stade pour cela il y a quatre
options qui sont envisagé dont une à
Montini le Bretonneux alors le PSG
serait intéressé par un terrain basé
près du Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline un site
accessible avec le rerc et qui séduit
les dirigeants parisiens grâce à sa
proximité avec le nouveau Training
Center de poissie le maire de la commune
Laurent Merker ne ferme pas la porte à
ce projet et on reste à Montini le
Bretonneau Gabriel où ce soir auront
lieu les assises de l'éducation oui ça
se passe à partir de
19h45 dans la salle Jacques brê la
commune organise ses assises de
l'éducation objet objectif Imagineer la
construction de l'école primaire de
demain avec la participation des parents
des agents périscolaires et l'éducation
national ce projet doit être
opérationnel pour la rentrée 2025 on
écoute l'adjoint au maire Yannick LEDOR
Montini comme l'ensemble des villes de
l'agglomération est issue de la ville
nouvelle nous avons connu une très forte
et un très fort développement
démographique lors des années 90 et
aujourd'hui on a un tassement de cette
évolution démographique avec évidemment
un impact sur nos écoles inimontaines
que ce soit pour les enfants de maternel
ou les enfants de l'élémentaire et
l'idée c'est bah d'anticiper sur les
évolutions à venir et de programmer la
nouvelle école que nous voulons à
Montigny pour les années à venir pour
suivre cette soirée rendez-vous sur le
compte Youtube de la commune à partir de
19h45 et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
news en France un établissement sur deux
n'est pas adapt aux personnes à mobilité
réduite une problématique qui touche
l'entreprise axol située à trappe cette
dernière souhaite favoriser
l'accessibilité des lieux à tout le
monde elle fabrique et commercialise une
vingtaine de produits différents Julien
Leroi s'est rendu sur place sans aucun
effort et l'accessibilité pour tous
attrape axol importe et distribue des
solutions techniques pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite dispositif d'accès
pour les piscines plateformes
élévatrices ou chaise d'évacuation de
quoi rendre la société plus inclusive en
raison de son histoire personnelle
Jean-Paul Mignard fonde l'entreprise en
2010 il se trouve qu'à l'âge de 55 ans
mon grand-père mon père est devenu ém
plégique suite à un AVC j'avais 6 ans à
l'époque et B j'ai vécu toute ma
jeunesse observer que pour ma famille
c'était extrêmement compliqué de lui
faire participer à toutes les activités
familiales pendant une vingtaine
d'années où il fallait le le porter en
permanence il voulait pas quitter sa
maison dans qu'il avait construit dans
lequel il a il avait toujours
vécu suite à la sessation d'activité
d'un fournisseur anglais Jean-Paul
Mignard a relocalisé une partie de la
fabrication de ces produits depuis 2020
cette rampe d'accès en fibre de verre
est conçue à trrappe d'un coup d'environ
700 € elle permet notamment à un
fauteuil roulant d'accéder à un balcon
ou une terrasse cette rample a la
particularité de pouvoir se se rabattre
voilà ça permet le le franchissement
d'un obstacle qui est tout simplement
une baie vitrée et ça permettra à la
personne de refermer sa sa sa fenêtre en
laissant le matériel en place quoi un
manque de d'accessibilité dans de
nombreux déplacements en France seule la
moitié des structures recevant du public
restent praticable pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite autant des des des des
gros établissements type des banques des
grandes chaînes de magasins et cetera
sont accessibles par contre tout ce qui
est petit commerce tout ce qui est
petite commune et cetera ont pris
beaucoup de retard pour diverses raisons
pour des problèmes de coût ben aussi
quelquefois de simplement de bonne
volonté des exploitants qui on entend
encore certains qui disent ben pourquoi
j'ai m'équiper alors que je reçois
personne en situation dehicap chez moi
plus de 5000 produits ont été vendus par
la société Axel en 2023 pour donner
davantage d'autonomie l'entreprise
testent actuellement des prototypes
contrôle des rampes via le panneau de
commande du fauteuil ou un smartphone
une commercialisation espéré dans les
prochaines années pour rendre notre pays
plus
inclusif allez c'est l'heure de passer à
notre page
[Musique]
loisir
et on débute cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend
Gabrielle et on commence avec un
événement à Versailles oui on commence
avec un petit blind test mathil est-ce
que vous reconnaissez ce
[Musique]
titre écrit par John Lennon sorti en
1969 et si je vous parle des Beatles
Mathilde c'est que le célèbre groupe
britannique reprend vie le temps d'une
semaine à Versailles au cyano au
programme des vendredis une comédie
musicale construite avec des reprises du
groupe samedi c'est une comédie sur un
monde parallèle où les Beatles
n'auraient jamais existé qui est proposé
à noté également un concert live avec
l'un des groupes hommage officiels de
boot leg Beatles tout droit venu de
Londres et cet événement Mathilde il est
organisé pour le 60e anniversaire du
passage des Beatles dans la ville
c'était le 15 janvier 1964 au cyano de
Versailles c'était d'ailleurs leur
premier concert en France c'était leur
premier concert en France premier
concert en France d'accord on poursuit
en en musique Gabriel mais dans un style
un peu différent oui on passe du rock à
la house et même à la hardarde techno
avec un événement qui a lieu à la
batterie de Guy en cours au programme
une soirée techno avec des DJ du
territoire parmi les artistes
châteaubillant la terrasse ou encore
Drax rendez-vous demain soir d 20h à la
batterie du théâtre maintenant au prisme
d'élancour après avoir joué partout en
France la Comédia de la Bliss et de
passage dans les Yveline oui et la
compagnie de spectacle propose samedi
soir la pièce Péry colossau de Gérard
Levoyer une comédie à la fois romantique
et dramatique qui invite à la réflexion
on écoute l'un des comédiens au micro de
Michael elmidoro c'est une petite
histoire d'amour entre deux
personnages qui ont à peu près une une
vingtaine d'années de de différence
et un peu aigri par par la vie de tous
les jours et un sujet traité avec avec
humour et gravité en même temps pour
découvrir le spectacle rendez-vous au
prisme d'élancour c'est samedi des 20h
et jusqu'au 11 février 2024 la danse est
à l'honneur sur le territoire de Grand
Paris saéoise avec la 4e bienénale de la
danse oui et pour cette année olympique
près de 40 événements sont organ réparti
sur 16 communes deux événements ont
retenu mon attention ce weekend une
exposition à mantelaville intitulé
entrer dans la danse qui explore le lien
étroit entre le sport et la danse avec
une attention portée à tous les types de
danse du hip hop au breaking en passant
par la danse contemporaine et la danse
classique autre rendez-vous ce weekend à
her avec un spectacle où l'art de la
danse et le basket évolue ensemble et on
termine vos idées de sortie Gabriel avec
du cirque du cirque à l'île de loisirs
de Saint-Quentin en yeline durant tout
le mois de janvier dans son spectacle
l'absolu Boris JB combine acrobatie
danse et questions existentielles tout
ça évoluant dans un gigantesque silo
conçu pour l'occasion loin du chapitau
traditionnel cette configuration permet
au public un angle d'observation inédit
promettant une expérience originale oui
ça a l'air intéressant effectivement
merci beaucoup Gabriel pour toutes ces
idées de sortie on poursuit cette page
loisir avec un match de football
américains samedi prochain les Templiers
d'élancour devraient jouer leur premier
match de la saison contre les météores
de fontené sous bois on écoute
l'entraîneur de l'équipe au micro de
Gabriel
[Musique]
Gontier bonne préparation physique on
est parti sur 5 à 6 semaines euh prépa
physiquegr football américain puisque
cette année en fait on a un effectif qui
se modifie de de plus en en
plus on a un groupe senior pour parler
de l'équipe senior pour l'instant qui
est assez complet ettau Faé
contrairement aux autres années on a un
bon nombre de joueurs c'est-à-dire qu'on
a entre 40 et 50 licenciers je crois
seniors contrairement à l'année dernière
on en avait une trentaine donc on a fait
un bon
recrutement continue faire réuner le
club avoir des performances mais comme
on l'a dit déjà je répète toujours la
même chose comme on l'a dit les autres
années euh nous on a une autre vision
aussi qui qu'on veut mettre en avant en
fait euh on veut revenir on veut revenir
dans la vie encs comme un acteur un
acteur social et un acteur sportif le
sportif on l'a déjà les templés dans en
cours sont connu et reconnus maintenant
acteur social on va participer à la vie
de la
[Musique]
ville un affrontement qui aura lieu si
les conditions météo le permettent et
d'ailleurs c'est l'heure de votre
bulletin météo
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir de
belles éclaircis sur la partie sud-ouest
des Yvelines par contre le ciel sera
plus nuageux du côté de Mantel jolie et
de Houdan au niveau des température ça
remonte légèrement on ne sera plus dans
le négatif c'est déjà ça compte 3°gr à
Mantel jolie et 1°gr à versaillil
rouillé et ouddant l'après-midi le ciel
se couvre sur une bonne partie du
département seul le secteur de versaill
sera épargné côté température il fera
4°gr à Mantel jolie et 3°gr à Houdan
rambouillé et versaill pour les
prévisions météo de ce weekend samedi le
soleil sera présent mais les
températures redescendent il fera en
moyenne - 2°gr le matin et 2°gr
l'après-midi dimanche le ciel sera
nuageux sur l'ensemble du département et
il fera environ 0°g le matin et 2°gr
l'après-midi alors couvrez-vous bien
c'est l'heure à présent de l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir nous sommes avec le maire
de coignère Didier ficher bonsoir
bonsoir bonne année 2024 meillen aussi
il a toute la rédaction et toutes les
équipes et moi j'allais dire à tous les
quanériens et les Quan on dit comme ça
alors première question Didier Fiser
quel bilan faites-vous de de l'année
2023 dans votre commune ah ben c'est
fait une bonne année une année riche en
projet on a bien avancé sur le théâtre
d'Odet une rénovation thermique qui est
achevée aujourd'hui donc ça c'est quand
même quelque chose de de fondamental on
a démarré les travaux de laera la
résidence autonomie là aussi c'est
quelque chose d'important parce que nos
personnes âgées avaient besoin de plus
de confort notamment dans les salles de
bain et on refait tout le
rez-de-chaussée qu'on isole aussi d'une
manière thermique et puis on met on
refait des salle une salle de restaurant
des salles d'activités de qualité donc
c'est quand même là déjà de beaux
projets qui ont eu lieu dans cette
année 2023 on a ça a été aussi l'année à
baépierre à à coignère et c'était
important parce que les valeurs de la
baépierre on a essayé de les mettre en
avant dans notre belle commune et ça a
bien marché autour de je dirais
d'activités importantes les jeunes les
moins jeunes des expositions expositions
sur la baieperre ça a été l'occasion
pour les coiriens de découvrir au moins
pour les plus jeunes de découvrir cet
homme et ça a été une belle année en
quelque sorte l'année 2023 a aussi été
marqué par l'inflation un contexte
financier compliqué pour les
collectivités est-ce que ça va est-ce
que à cause de ce contexte compliqué
vous allez augmenter les impôts locaux
euh non non nous naugmenterons pas en
2024 les impôts je l'ai fait en 2023 je
l'ai fait sur le budget 2023 et je
m'engage évidemment à ne pas les
augmenter en 2024 en fait ce que l'on
fait c'est que l'on va poursuivre les
économies d'énergie notamment notre plan
de sobriété énergétique nous allons le
le maintenir et il a porté ses fruits là
cette année puisque selon les sites de
la commune c'est entre 10 et 30 %
d'économie en matière de gaz et
d'électricité quand on sait que le gaz
augmenté de 300 % et l'électricité nous
on a pris 72 ou 73 % d'augmentation euh
pouvez imaginer que d'avoir pu faire au
moins 30 % 10 à 30 %
d'économie en terme de consommation hein
je dis bien pas en terme puisqu'on a
payé évidemment plus cher il a fallu que
j'aille chercher un million d'euros
supplémentaire quand même à ce budget
c'est pour ça que j'ai augmenter les
impôts aussi on aurait pas eu ce
problème là on augmentait pas les impôts
c'est évident alors beaucoup de travaux
de de rénovation notamment
énergétique aussi l'année prochaine la
rénovation du groupe scolaire bouvé
les travaux vont commencer quand bah ils
commencent ils commencent en ce moment
on a posé les premiers algco puisqu'on
fait une rénovation avec les élèves sur
site hein donc on a on a posé les
premiers algco la fin du mois de
décembre et là les premiers travaux
démar au 1er février je crois que le
chantier battra son plein alors c'est
quand même on a phasé hein ces travaux
il y a trois phases de travaux sur 18
mois une première phase qui va consister
à construire un restaurant scolaire on
mutualise école maternelle école
élémentaire ensuite on va faire
l'école maternelle deuxème phase et puis
enfin l'école élémentaire et là on a une
vraie rénovation thermique hein par
l'extérieur on isole les murs par
l'extérieur on change un certain nombre
de vitrag bien entendu et on rénove
l'intégralité aussi de l'école salle par
salle parquet enfin disons sol plafond
enfin vous voyez et on la rend
accessible notamment pour l'école
élémentaire par un ascenseur à
l'extérieur de de l'école voilà et tout
ça ça représente quel coût environ pour
la ville on est on est sur un coût entre
je dirais un peu plus de 4 million
d'euros peut-être ça peut peut-être
aller jusqu'à 5 millions puisque vous
savez les chantiers c'est toujours
aléatoire hein mais on a quand même on a
quand même je dirais sur ce sur ce
chantier sur ce cette rénovation on va
quand même essayer de obtenir à peu près
50 % de cofinancement donc c'est 50 % de
4 millions 4 millions et demi
peut-être pour la commune réellement
alors dans les autres grands projets en
cours pour la ville il y a le renouveau
du quartier de la gare un projet qui a
débuté en 2022 où est-ce que on est ce
ce dossier ce projet alors on en est
dans l'étude tout d'abord puisqueil faut
commencer par une étude une étude et là
je salue 50 ans ieline hein puisque
c'est elle qui a la compétence dans ce
domaine et qui finance cette étude une
étude à 300000 € quand même he c'est pas
rien sur sur ce quartier puisque nous
souhaitons faire évoluer ce quartier
nous souhaitons y mettre de la mixité
fonctionnelle nous souhaitons créer un
véritable écoquartier pour je dirais
améliorer véritablement là euh cette cet
espace qui aujourd'hui je dirais euh est
problématique les habitants parce qu'il
y a quand même des habitants dans ce
quartier aujourd'hui se sentent plutôt
légué et cela il y a pas de service
public à part la gare vous n'avez pas de
service public donc cela pose problème
et puis il y a cette national 10 qui
quand même fracture notre ville et coupe
la ville donc coupe cette ville en deux
et pose un certain nombre de problèmes
des problèmes finalement d'accident des
problèmes de pollution des problèmes de
bruit donc tout cela doit être
considérablement amélioré et cette étude
vise à nous donner au moins je dirais
une orientation pour améliorer les
choses dans ce quartier mais vous
parliez de la N 10 la sécurité routière
vous en faites une priorité pour l'année
2024 ça veut dire quoi voilà c'était
déjà la priorité euh en 2023 puisque
nous sommes passés sur tout l'espace
résidentiel euh et notamment le centre
le vieux
village les les espaces pavillonnaires
nous sommes passés à 30 km/h on est
passé de 50 à 30 km he et puis nous
réfléchissons je dirais à faire en sorte
aussi de faire ce que l'on appelle ce
qui est fait d'ailleurs dans certaines
villes des zones de rencontre des zones
vin
rencontrre automobilistes piéton vélo
donc c'est c'est un système qui
normalement sécurise en effet
considérablement ces lieux où on les met
en place quoi vous demandez également
est-ce que la vitesse soit réduite sur
la National 10 oui alors ça c'est un
projet plus plus large c'est dans le
cadre d'une requalification qu'on
demande une requalification de la
nationale 10
avec puisque je le disais fracture notre
commune enfin c'est un vrai un vrai
souci elle a fait notre richesse mais
aujourd'hui elle nous pose un certain
nombre de problèmes malgré tout donc
l'idée c'est un projet global l'idée
c'est de faire un aménagement au
carrefour des fontaines type peut-être
ce qui est fait sur trappe aujourd'hui
avec le rond-point le passage
sous-terrain enfin des choses de ce type
quelque chose qui nous permett
finalement de mieux circuler parce que
là c'est un nœud d'engorgement et
d'accident qui est quand même problém
et puis ensuite la la suite en quelque
sorte en direction de Rambouillet serait
plus sur un boulevard urbain et pour
obtenir ce boulevard urbain
effectivement l'idée c'est de diminuer
la vitesse de passer de 70 à 50 km/h de
rétrécir les voies puis que ça ça nous
permet de rétrécir les voies justement
de diminuer la vitesse et de faire en
sorte qu'on puisse plus facilement la
franchir pour atteindre ce fameux
nouveau
quartier pas en jambe des bouchons de
rétrécir les voix je pense pas je pense
pas après garde la fluidité la
circulation au contraire si on fait ce
qui est fait par exemple sur trappe avec
ce ces rond-points on fluidifie en fait
la circulation on est plutôt dans dans
la fluidité parce que le problème c'est
que une fois qu'on aura fait trappe bah
les voitures vont nous arriver sur
coignerde de toute façon ça ça va pas
solutionner la la question coignerrienne
et coignerde restera la dernière ville
traversé de cette façonlà fracturé de
cette façon-là par la National 10 sur le
secteur donc il faut qu'on qu'on
améliore là et moi j'en ai fait une
condition quand même vis-à-vis de l'État
j'ai rencontré il y a pas très longtemps
laadirif qui a écouté avec attention euh
je dirais mes propos et qui est prêt à
commencer à réfléchir un peu à ces à ces
aménagements possibles euh l'idée c'est
vraiment de se dire on ne frapp pas euh
l'écoquartier on va pas construire faire
500 logements de l'autre côté de la
nationale 10 si on peut pas la traverser
en sécurité c'est pas possible on va
accroître au contraire on va faire on va
faire de villes quoi on va faire on va
faire une une autre ville à côté de la
première donc c'est pas c'est pas
raisonnable en quelque sorte donc ça
sera une des conditions cet aménagement
de la nationale 10 est une des
conditions pour construire ce quartier
de l'autre côté et comme l'état nous
demande de construire 500 logements euh
là aussi ça sera je pense une
négociation à voir avec l'État sur le
sujet quoi d'autant plus que projet par
de d'autres de d'autres projets
d'idifiant parce qu'on est un peu pris
par le temps côté patrimoine vous avez
déposé un dossier pour que l'église
Saint-Germain d'xer soit classée au
titre des monuments historiques quels
sont les atouts de cette église et
qu'est-ce que va permettre alors les
atouts ils sont nombreux parce que c'est
un très bel édifice et moi j'ai été
surpris depuis que je suis coagierien
c'est dire depuis 2007 de savoir que
cette église n'était pas
classée elle avait à l'intérieur
quelques éléments de classement mais
elle n'était pas elle n'était pas
classée alors qu'elle a je dirais
matière à être classée
on a des des vitreux remarquables on a
un vitrail du 16e siècle mais on a des
vitreux de Gabriel Loir qui est un des
grands maîtres vitriers français euh on
a une chapelle qui date de la première
Renaissance avec des sculptures
intéressantes euh donc ça aussi c'est
important on a une base une fondation de
l'Église qui est quand même du 12e
siècle une partie de la nef c'est le 12e
siècle donc du 12e au 20e siècle on a
une église qui a traversé le le les
ication elle permettra de rénover l'gise
alors en principe oui elle doit
permettre une une rénovation aussi de
l'église intérieur en tous les cas avec
des subventions qui pourraient être
obtenu si effectivement elle est classée
au monument historique on pourrait
peut-être obtenir jusqu'à 40 % de
subvention alors juste pour terminer d
fichur parce qu'il nous reste un peu
moins d'une minute je vais vous laisser
votre carte blanche c'est une carte
blancheon laisse à tous les maires de
Saint-Quentin enine vous voulez aborder
quel sujet ah mais non mais moi je
voulais aborderé la question de la
nationale 10 donccoup on en a on en a
déjà effectivement beaucoup parlé mais
je pense que c'est fondamental pour une
commune comme coignère de trouver une
solution j'ai interpellé aujourd'hui la
Région le
Département l'état de la région et du
département j'ai pas eu de réponse à
vrai dire de l'État je commence à avoir
des réponse donc j'espère effectivement
trouver assez rapidement une solution et
que l'on puisse réfléchir à un
amménagement concerté bien
entendu de cette nationale 10
excusez-moi c'est
l'hiver c'est l'hiver voilà mais je
pense qu'il y a là un vrai sujet un vrai
sujet qui permettra qui améliorera quand
même cette qualité de vie àignère et je
vous dis je vous ai expliqué en effet
que de
pouvoir faire cet aménagement sur le
carrefour des fontaines passer en
boulevard urbain végétaliser les abords
de cette de cette nationale en réduisant
grâce à la réduction de vitesse
l'emprise je pense que là voilà je pense
que c'est c'est vraiment fondamental je
ne demande pas un enfouissement total
parce que je sais que c'est pas possible
je comprends bien la situation à trpe on
est à 150 millions aujourd'hui on avait
commencé à 98 millions on est à 150
millions je pense que c'est un sujet à
coignère autour d'une quarantaine de
millions d'euros voilà qui est important
voilà bonne année2 merci à vous et
encore bonne année à vous et merci de
m'avoir accueilli merci avec plaisir
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée et un excellent weekend sur
tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous